[Musique]
deux journées de réflexion sur des
problématiques européennes et
martiniquaise forcément c'est le
colloque europe aux caraïbes organisé
par le parti démocratique européen
bonjour françois meyroune bonjour vous
êtes connu pour être président du modem
france co président du pdl parti
démocratique européen également vous
êtes un élu local puisque vous êtes
maire de cette ville de pau on parlera
donc françois bayroux de diplomatie de
résilience insulaire de changement
climatique et de financement de nos pme
mais françois veyrunes me semble quand
même qu'il ya un volet essentiel qu'il
manque le sujet comment convaincre les
martiniquais de leur appartenance à
l'europe ça ne semble pas essentiel ça
bonjour vous voyez que c'est un des
enjeux de la rencontre que nous allons
avoir pendant deux jours si je me mets à
la place des citoyens martiniquais de
ceux qui suivent la politique parce que
il y en a un certain nombre qui ne la
suivent pas ou plus si je me mets à leur
place qu est ce que je me dis jeudi les
responsables politiques notamment les
responsables politiques nationaux
ils viennent en martinique au moment des
élections parce que à ce moment là il
faut s'adresser à chacune des parties du
pays et évidemment les antilles
l'outre-mer comme on dit en noir ça
déplaît les régionales cette façon de
périphériques et ça agace beaucoup
notamment les martiniquais et je peux
parfaitement le comprendre et c'est
pourquoi ces deux jours dans ces deux
journées de rencontres
elles sont organisées précisément pour
qu' on puisse aborder les problèmes de
fond et c'est d'ailleurs intéressant
parce que je crois que toutes les
sensibilités politiques de la martinique
et de la guadeloupe vont participer à
cette rencontre
j'aimerais quand même qu'on revienne sur
un chiffre un seul il ya quand même plus
88 % d'abstention lors des dernières
européennes ça interpelle forcément les
les
ces pertes les personnes politiques les
personnalités politiques lorsque
lorsqu'on parle d'europe ici en
martinique
vous voyez ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que les citoyens martiniquais
femmes et hommes jeunes et moins jeunes
considèrent que c'est un problème qu'il
ne les touche pas d'un problème atari se
déroule à tort loin d'eux or il se
trouve que dans le monde dans lequel
nous vivons
si l'europe n'existait pas on n'aurait
pas les moyens de défendre des régions
comme les antilles comme lamartine et
comme la guadeloupe de s'adresser à ces
régions qui sont à la périphérie du
monde européen la géographie ne fait pas
tout oui vous savez que la culture la
langue la manière de voir les choses les
lois tout ça fait que les antilles et la
martinique en particulier sont une
partie intégrante de cette unité
française dans laquelle nous vivons et
dans laquelle nous voudrions vivre qu'il
faut renforcer et qu'il faut mobiliser
et donc aborder les problèmes qui sont
qui sont les vôtres
sous cet angle européen avec les moyens
de l'europe où la préoccupation de
l'europe c'est très important je vais
prendre un exemple vous avez abordé
pendant le journal la question des
sargasses ces algues qui dérive et
viennent depuis des années se jeter sur
les plages phénomène qui va se
multiplient et quand ces algues se
décompose
alors vous savez les dégâts que ça fait
des dégâts pour l'air que nous respirons
dégâts pour les maisons la corrosion des
maisons le
les moteurs des bateaux enfin tout c'est
toutes ces choses là vous voyez bien que
ce sont des questions qui doivent
trouver une réponse beaucoup plus large
que la réponse d'un seul pays d'un seul
état éligibles au statut de catastrophe
naturelle baï fofana deviennent alors
qu'est ce que l'union européenne
pourrait pourrait proposer sur leur
satisfait difficile ne confondons pas
première chose la question de
catastrophe naturelle c'est une question
française c'est une loi française que
les élus à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat le gouvernement doivent accepter
de classe et pour que les assurances
puissent intervenir
et de ce point de vue là il est de la
responsabilité du devoir à mes yeux deux
du gouvernement et
du parlement de classer ce type de
choses en catastrophe naturelle car c'en
est ouverte et par nos députés par nos
sénateurs c'en est une
et pour ma part je le soutiendrai mais
ça n'est pas que ça il ya deux choses au
moins est ce qu'on peut prévenir la
dérive de ces algues ce qu'on peut faire
des barrages par exemple pour ainsi dire
dans à la à la surface de la mer qui y
en a non il se trouve qu'il y en a
deuxièmement à long terme on voit bien
ce qui ce qui se passe c'est quoi les
sargasses ces algues là c'est de la
matière vivante si c'est de la matière
vivante on peut en faire de la biomasse
on peut faire en sorte que ça produisent
de la chaleur ou de l'énergie de
l'électrique donc développer un pôle
recherche
il faut développer un pôle recherche et
un pool technologie parce que c'est pas
d'une technologie sim compliqué mais
françois bayroux les hits et on en à non
mais on n'y est ni je passe vers
lesquels j'avais bien dit mais le tout
c'est une question de moyens et de
volonté parce que des algues est mort si
le phénomène s'est accentué ces derniers
mois ces dernières semaines ce n'est pas
nouveau ça a déjà existé mais moi c'est
la raison pour laquelle je ne parle pas
d'idées générales
je parle d'eux concret vous savez que
nous avons en métropole en bretagne en
particulier il ya eu des phénomènes de
cet ordre développement d'algues en
particulier parce que les engrais azotés
faisait créer un milieu dans lesquelles
les et à la thèse développée et ces
algues vertes
on peut les traiter et même des gens qui
en font soit des engrais soit des
nutriments tour pour les êtres vous
prenez françois donc jusqu'à concret
vous avez parlé d'agacement justement
puisque ce phénomène s'est déjà produit
là-bas que nous sommes sûr nous faisons
partie de cette même entité géographique
pourquoi cela prend t-il autant de temps
que la solution appliquée là-bas le sois
ici c'est parce qu'il ya vraiment 6000
8000 km entre nous et non
poussée dans mes retranchements mais je
vais répondre pourquoi un des problèmes
de la france c'est que nous avons un
état qui est un état souvent paralysé
souvent enlisée qu'il ya des procédures
extrêmement lourdes vous me parliez de
reconnaissance de catastrophe naturelle
il faut des textes et des textes et
l'état est un état qui mène à rappeler
que les meilleurs travaux on rappelle
que vous invitez membres de gouvernement
que nous à fréquenter des plus hautes
sphères politiques de ce pays
et bien si vous gagnez votre action trop
accélérer ce genre ne vous avez eu la
gentillesse de suivre mon action
politique
elle a été constamment tourné diriger
vers efficace et enfin retrouver de la
vitesse d'exécution
enfin retrouver de l'efficacité enfin
retrouvé des réponses et arrêter de se
laisser paralyser par l'administration
avec un grand h qui dans les sphères les
plus éloignés pas celle qui est sur le
terrain mais dans les sphères les plus
éloignés ont toujours vous le savez bien
les mêmes réflexes les mêmes prudence et
au bout du compte ça débouche assez
souvent sur de l'immobilisme montée
cadre à lantin et frustré nos inventeurs
qui est tel que ça désespère les gens
alors de l'adisq m'interroger sur la
ville dont j'ai la chance d'être le
maire qui est une ville formidable que
beaucoup de martinique et connaissent il
se trouve que j'ai en effet fait le pari
en étant élu que nous allions multiplier
par trois ou par 4 la rapidité
d'exécution des choses ce qui fait qu'au
bout de quatre années de mandat
la totalité ou presque du programme que
nous avions présenté aux électeurs est
réalisée alors qu'il aurait fallu
peut-être 15 ans ou 20 ans pour le faire
pour soi mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
vous le sentez bien une énergie qui est
très grande et c'est sur cette énergie
là que le président de la république a
été élu c'est sur 7
sur cette volonté-là de bousculer des
choses qui nous paralyse est depuis
mille ans dans le monde de la politique
et dans le monde de la vente à qu'il a
aimée ribeiro ce verrou restons en
martinique s'il vous plaît vous avez
entendu parler de du tcsp le transport
en commun en site propre c'est un projet
qui date de mathusalem près de 300
millions 400 millions sur la table pour
un tracé de 14 millions ça ne fonctionne
pas l'europe a mis des billes là dedans
un prêt de 80 millions d'euros
ces deux projets qui ne voient pas le
jouet qui devenu la risée de l'ensemble
du monde politique de la part de la
population qui elle est excédé vous
diriez quoi par exemple pour
responsables politiques de celui que
vous allez rencontrer
concernant ce tcsp écoutez vous en tout
cas comme citoyens c'est à vous de dire
les choses moi quand je la joue les
photos - est-ce que tu connais pas je ne
connais pas les responsabilités mais je
c'est forcément qu'il y en a n'est ce
pas l'europe qui met de l'argent pour la
prochaine qui fonctionne pas il se
trouve que alors c'est pas la même
échelle mais un transport en commun en
site propre
ce qu'on appelle un bhns chez nous la 14
bus il se trouve que nous on bâtit son
dans ma ville qui va ouvrir dans un an
douze mois et qui sera le premier au
monde à hydrogène
parce que vous voyez bien que la
question du transport elle est liée à la
question de l'environnement
elle est liée à la question du
réchauffement de la planète et qu'on a
maintenant des moyens des méthodes et
des
pratiques qui peuvent nous permettre
d'échapper au gaz à effet de serre à la
multiplication des listes émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en hydrogène
c'est une manière de entraîner des bus
électriques et en même temps de leur
donner la même blague vous nous vendez
du rêve la pollution des mois tous dans
les voir rouler ses bus là mais il reste
donnez moi de vous dire ça c'est votre
affaire
ouais je vous le dis sans optant pour
nous ce n'est pas faire des journaux
polémique non c'est votre affaire
il n'est pas vrai j'entendais ça tout à
l'heure dans une émission
il n'est pas vrai que tous doivent se
régler à votre place
c'est la responsabilité des citoyens
c'est la responsabilité de l'opinion
publique martiniquaise que de se tourner
vers ses élus en disant mais quelle est
la raison
on constate une espèce de panne générale
du système quelle est la raison pour
vous et lui expliquer nos au moins ce
qui n'a pas marché parce que quand on
sait ce qui n'a pas marché on peut
corriger et changer les choses encore
faudrait-il que certains élus viennent
lorsqu on les invite
dernière question soit bureau oui mais
oui on peut venir peut pas
malheureusement obligé les personnes à
venir semi crise et cette élection alors
une dernière question parce qu'il nous
reste vraiment trop de secondes le
financement des pme ce sera un des
thèmes de ce colloque sur deux jours on
est loin d'avoir épuisé toutes les
possibilités ou bien faut-il encore
imaginer de nouveaux montages financiers
on a vraiment 20 secondes alors est ce
que ces deux nouveaux montages
financiers qu'il faut trouver où c'est
au contraire la question des charges
qu'il faut aborder différemment
lorsqu'on se trouve en martinique où
lens coraux ou lorsqu'on se trouve au
coeur de la métropole
il ya une adaptation pour les
entreprises des règles qui leur sont
imposées selon la région dans laquelle
elle se développe
vous savez qu'on a fait ça pour un
certain nombre de banlieue je suis
absolument persuadé que dans la région
caraïbe où vous vous trouvez alors il y
à des adaptations à trouver en fonction
de l'environnement économique dans
lequel vous êtes notamment du prévu des
charges
merci d'avancé se bat avec nos francs
soit mais aura-t-elle vous êtes maire de
pau président du modem et coprésident du
parti démocratique européenne le
colloque ces deux pendant deux jours à
labatut relire bonne journée
[Musique]